religion is a habit of virtue that
inclines the will to render to God what
he deserves and wokeness is a bunch of
nonsense so when you put the two
together you wind up a little bit more
on the nonsense side of things as we see
with this series of woke religion Tik
toks God never said that a woman cannot
be a preacher you can't prove that with
the scripture pause right there he did
though dang it's there in the writings
of St Paul and you might say well St
Paul isn't God but St Paul is writing in
the New Testament and all scripture is
inherent and inspired by God you you
guys ever go to Sunday school even if
you don't believe in the authority of
the church and you just say I go to my
Bible and I interrogate my Bible with my
own individual interpretive principle
even still you would have to say that
ladies are not meant to be preachers if
it wasn't the will of God for a woman to
preach or teach then why does it say
that Aquilla and his wife Priscilla were
over a church that was in inside their
house basically she was a co-pastor Oh
no in John
20:17 Jesus told Mary to go tell the
other disciples that he ascended to the
father it was a woman but I thought
women couldn't preach though matter of
fact we can't forget Phoebe right most
don't even know who she is yet the Bible
says that she was a servant in the
church that word servant originally
means that she was a teacher or a pastor
and that word that doesn't line up with
what I'm trying to say I'm I'm just
going to change what that word means
[Music]
okay righty
then so I guess the question that this
woke guy has got to ask himself is why
is it the Christians for about 1800
years excepting the last 100 200 years
they all thought that women are not
supposed to be priests why is it what
did they all get wrong that this guy got
right what
[Music]
changed put a pause there if you begin
your preaching by saying Jesus was I'm
just going to tune out done because it
means you fundamentally misunderstand
the Christian religion which is based on
the crucifixion and resurrection of our
Lord Jesus Christ
is and we actually know his race by the
way he's a Jew we know that because it's
in all of the scripture and it's where
he was born and it's his people we know
his mother we even I think have a pretty
good sense of what he looks like because
we have the shroud of Trin so we know a
lot and they'll say Jesus wasn't white
okay well Jesus isn't Scandinavian
that's true he also isn't
Nigerian he's he's a
Jew Palestinian okay
okay racism is evil racism is evil isn't
it I don't know what racism really means
anymore but racism these days is just
defined as evil so I guess that's a
truism evil is evil the rest of what he
said a bit dubious hello and welcome to
conservative drag queen Story Hour where
we only tell stories from books that
Christian conservatives appr in today's
story we're covering the verse where
Jesus Christ condones child abuse you're
kidding me right are you kidding you're
kidding we got Jesus teaching these
parents over here how to be a good
parent Jesus asked why do you refuse to
obey God's command the Lord said you
must respect your father and mother oh
well that sounds nice don't it I've
heard that one quoted back to me by my
parents I know you if any child says
anything bad to their father or mother
he must must be put to un alive well
this took a dark turn but you teach that
a child can say to their father or
mother I have something I could use put
a pause here what the hell is this guy
talking about I don't even what is he
even reading from at first I thought he
was trying to read from scripture but
he's not what what are we in junior high
school like what the hell what is this
I'm all for taking on these woke
religion people and trying to make
arguments but this guy is just a
disgusting blasphemy and he should be
completely anathema and he he should he
should correct his evil sacrilegious
ways it's just disgusting and I I I
won't bear it okay I won't stand for
someone to lie about our Lord and savior
and to to make up this nonsense to
advance this disgusting perversions
right now go to Jus cell.com
nsyt everyone here at the office loves
the Jus Cell Dark Spot Corrector you
might be asking what this product even
does well if you've got sunspots dark
spots discoloration or dry skin the
genus Cell Dark Spot Corrector will will
help those blemishes disappear in front
of your very eyes Kimberly from youngst
Ohio says my appearance has improved so
much since using genucel I love all my
genus cell products and my skin looks
younger now it's your turn to feel like
Kimberly but hurry this sale is ending
very soon take advantage of genus cell's
most popular package which includes the
Beloved Dark Spot Corrector this package
also includes the genus cell classic
under eye treatment you will get all
these products for almost 70 70% off Jus
cell is so confident in their products
that you can try them for yourself
completely risk-free if you don't see
immediate results you will get your
money back it's very simple go to
jus.com nsyt start looking years even
decades younger tomorrow say goodbye to
dark in liver spots bags and puffiness
under the eyes Crow feed at Jus cell.com
letter y letter T jus.com
nsyt being a pro-choice Christian is
something that is very looked down upon
within the church and it is something
that I have never understood because it
is very apparent that one of the number
one gifts that God gives us is the
opportunity to have free will and to
make decisions for ourselves he said you
get to decide if you want to take up
your cross and follow me you get to
decide if you want to live a life of
worship you get to decide if you want to
believe that my son actually came down
on Earth to die for you that is your
decision and I'm not forcing that upon
you you put a pause there yes we do have
free will and we can either turn our
will toward God and cooperate with God's
grace and do things that are conducive
to our flourishing here on Earth and in
heaven so that we can enjoy God forever
or we can abuse our free will and turn
away from God and burn in hell for
eternity so she's right as often the
woke religion
people will be they'll have like a
little tiny kernel of an almost truth in
there somewhere but then they will come
to the completely wrong conclusions and
ignore the point of that which is which
is also that actions have consequences
Jesus also very much value free will he
didn't force the Pharisees into
believing what he was saying he
challenged them he spoke to them
rationally and valued them as people but
he never forced them into believing what
he believed so why are we trying to
force our beliefs on other people if
we're supposed to be mirroring the life
of Jesus and being more like him every
single day we need to
Value the ability to make a choice and
that is pro-choice the point that she
has right is that we have free
[Music]
will this does not mean however that the
Civil Authority ought to allow all
manner of evil like the slaughter of
babies or any other type of crime so
that the Civil Authorities there for our
good and the laws are therefore our good
and the Civil laws the positive law is
derived from the natural law the moral
law According to which we can know with
100% certainty it is wrong to murder
little babies don't do that okay okay
there's nothing anti-christian about
that in fact our Lord himself explicitly
upholds that princip if Jesus was alive
today and he did his whole thing today
you know who he would hang out with he
would hang out with furries he would
hang out with sex workers he would hang
out with drag queens he would hang out
with party kids at Raves and in BDSM
clubs he would hang out in all those
places that the pious Pharisees despise
he hung out with women which were one of
the most marginalized groups of the time
he would not go to the Republic National
Convention okay put a PO there so he he
was right up until that part you know
where Jesus would be if he were alive he
would be in places where Sinners are he
is man God is ever he's just begging you
to to turn to him and to accept his
grace he's begging you and he he will
meet you in the lowest most disgusting
degenerate Place far worse places even
than that guy can name he's especially
there that's very true where he goes
wrong though he says he wouldn't be at
the Republican National Convention no
he's there too he is there he's there
he's he's alive and if Christian
Republicans think that they're the side
of the oppressed and not the oppressor I
am begging them to read the part where
Jesus went into the temple and flipped
the tables because these that were
commercializing Christianity you're
using it for your own gain Jesus would
hate you they told me so the oppressor
is Satan who prows about the world
seeking the ruin of Souls and we are
oppressed in that way and then we also
can become tools of evil and do very
Terrible Things by abusing our free will
if you choose the quick and easy path
you will become an agent of evil and
this is why the people who use this kind
of language about the oppressor and the
oppressed usually coming out of some
gleaning of a Marxist tradition will
speak with with Zeal that matches or is
sometimes even stronger than the Zeal of
a Christian because that that is a
perversion of Christianity all of
leftism is a perversion of Christianity
and these guys just like bigots will be
often right about the other people
they'll be right yeah we're I'm a
miserable sinner yep but they're just
wrong about themselves so that they
don't see their own problems and their
own need of of Savior you lay
down I would be set
[Music]
free w Jesus I sing for all that you've
done for
[Music]
me